you keep defining abortion as the murder
of babies which biological factors you
would say most abortions are done before
they are actually babies it's still just
a fetus so my kids know what the word
fetus means it's just a cluster
into a baby eventually the word fetus
it's a Latin word and it just means
Offspring that's all it means it just
means the next generation of a being so
but that's what a baby is also I mean
that's what your adult you would call
your adult child someday once he's grown
hopefully if he hasn't been can I ask my
question well I'd just like to clarify
this point you would call your adult
child your Offspring too but all of
these terms that you might use fetus
embryo the one they love is zygote which
sounds like a Pokemon but they use all
these different terms but it's all
referring to the same being and you were
that being once you the person who's
standing here right now do any of us
have a memory of being that
the memory of last Thursday frankly it's
been a very busy week but the lack of a
memory doesn't mean that it's all right
to murder me